I think the answer to all of these
things is just transparency the more we
know about what these units are and what
they're doing who runs them and how they
make the decisions that they make the
more confidence the government can
expect people to have in the work
they're doing
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator offices in London last week
the telegraph published a very important
story they revealed that the counter
disinformation unit had been set up by
the conservative government during
lockdown to counter disinformation
supposedly or suppress Free Speech as
others are saying online this report was
described by Elon Musk as terrible here
to discuss it it's author of the
investigation and Whitehall
correspondent for the telegraph Tony
diver Tony thank you for joining me
morning well congratulations on what I
consider a very important piece can you
can you tell me what you discovered what
what's the significance of this story
well what we revealed in that story is
that there were two units operating at
the heart of government during the
pandemic which were scouring the
internet Twitter Facebook and everywhere
else newspapers looking for views that
they consider to be disinformation about
covid they were and it was set up based
on legitimate concerns about uh
conspiracy theories spreading about
vaccines and and the like you know we've
all seen those on the internet we've
seen some of that damaging uh content
but they set up basically to look for
this disinformation but what happened
was these units cast their Nets very
wide and what they did was scooped up a
lot of dissenting views on the internet
people saying quite legitimate things
about the government's response to the
pandemic about the closure of schools
for instance requiring children to wear
masks in schools lots of the stuff that
we now consider to be a fair game in
terms of talking about the impacts of
lockdown and what happened during the
pandemic and the policy decisions that
were made
those people had their content flagged
inside the cabinet office and inside
dcms in Whitehall and then though that
pieces of content were then passed back
to Twitter and Facebook and the
government told them we think this
breaks your terms of service and you
should take it down
um and so these two units have been
operating one of them has been operating
since 2018 well before the pandemic but
the government doesn't really like
talking about them because it sounds
quite Sinister basically it sounds like
the sort of thing
um you know that you hear of the
authoritarian regimes you know the
government monitoring what people are up
to online so the government tries not to
speak too much about it what we did was
uncover these units what they were doing
the content they were flagging and the
people who were making those arguments
behind the scenes uh and and we revealed
to the public that actually what you
were doing online during the pandemic
was according to the government very
much their concern so the you've got
this information from uh this the lead
civil or the Civil Service servant who
who then was appointed leader of this
unit Sarah is that is that correct how
did you get the information from this
well we know we knew that the units had
been operating the names of the units
there's two of them the rapid response
unit in the cabinet office which has
been operating since 2018 and was
originally set up to tackle
misinformation surrounding the Syrian
War
um and the covetism the other counter
disinformation unit in in TCMS we knew
about them we sort of officially they
did exist they had been mentioned in
Parliament
um but what we uncovered was was people
who had sent subject access requests to
the government under Freedom of
Information laws to say what information
do you hold about me and you know how's
your unit been monitoring what I've been
saying online and discovered that that
had been happening and so you know we
interviewed several campaigners and
normal people who were just making
arguments on the internet about covid
um who had then discovered subsequently
from from their requests that the
government had been monitoring what
they'd been saying and in some cases
passing that information on back to
Twitter and Facebook in an attempt to
get it taken down so um what we did
really was put some meat on the bones in
terms of those units went beyond the
official government line which is to say
very little about what those teams were
up to and expose what the government
actually considered to be disinformation
during the pandemic we and you know
others who've commented on the story
since including Elon Musk think they
were going to be casting that a little
bit too wide yeah there's a there's a
wider context here because it was only
at the end of last year that the Twitter
files were
were published with journalists Michael
schellenberger Matt Toby and Barry Weiss
amongst others upon must take over of
Twitter but what we saw there was how
the FBI and American governmental
agencies were in corresponding with
Twitter and they were they were telling
them flagging things that they should
they should be taking down and it seems
like a similar thing was happening here
in Britain actually Isabel oakshot
revealed earlier this year that as early
as February 2020 Hancock had been
talking to I think Nick Clegg it was at
Facebook about how to take things off
social media so what what was the what
does it look like the operations from
this British unit and the American
tech companies what what was that
relationship what do we know about how
they were operating well we don't know
fully we don't understand exactly how
those conversations happen because a lot
of them happen behind closed doors but
perhaps I could just sketch out the sort
of structure of the whole thing for you
um there was the counter disinformation
unit was a team of civil servants based
in dcms culture media and Sport
Department which has now been separated
off and the unit still exists sits in
the science and technology department
now in Whitehall and the remit that it
was given was to look for disinformation
on the internet which could contribute
towards narratives about vaccines and
about lockdown and about code pandemic
that were false that would
um you know give the wrong idea to the
public about what was really happening
and the feeling in government was that
that could potentially be damaging in
terms of people following lockdown rules
or um not taking the vaccine all these
sorts of Public Health measures that the
government wanted people to follow so
that was the remit of the unit it was a
team of civil servants
um the two main ways that we know that
they sort of scooped up this information
was through scouring social media and
we know that they actually contracted a
third-party company to do that they
contracted a uh an AI firm based in
Yorkshire do we know the name yes it's
called logically and we've spoken to
logically they've explained to us what
they were doing they were given a
government contract they were paid about
a million and a half pounds over the
course of the pandemic and they used an
AI algorithm basically to search Twitter
and Facebook to look for Content which
flagged the suggestion of disinformation
narratives and that content was then
passed back to dcms and TCMS then had
what is called a trusted Flagger status
with both Twitter and Facebook which
means that if you or I saw something on
Twitter that we thought maybe breached
the terms of service maybe maybe it was
abusive or you know wrong or whatever
you can report it all the social media
firms have a have a function to do that
but the government has a special
relationship with these organizations
which means that essentially their stuff
that they fly goes to the top of the
queue and it gets looked at straight
away by the administrators of those
social media sites so there was a sort
of a little ecosystem going on there
where AI Bots that were run by private
third-party companies passed into the
government the government then reviewed
those
put them into a spreadsheet we've seen
those spreadsheets and then Flags things
that they thought were in breach of
terms of service to Twitter and Facebook
and we know that during the pandemic at
the height the pandemic they were in
contact with those social media
companies on an hourly basis so they
were speaking they were speaking to them
all the time uh about stuff that they
thought should be taken down and
actually when you look at those lists of
things
um I think you'd be surprised to see
that some of the stuff that the
government thought maybe in breach of
the terms of service or thought should
be flagged because it's people
expressing opinions about what policy
Direction the government should take as
opposed to spreading lies about the
pandemic was there anything particularly
that struck your your eye as
alarming that it was that it was uh
signaled well I think the one that
sticks to my mind most was a campaign of
Molly Kingsley who's the she's she's at
the campaign group called us for them as
a children's campaign group set up
during the pandemic which basically
campaigned for schools to be opened
earlier or not shut down at all for kids
not to have what to wear masks in
classrooms for social distancing rules
to be relaxed in classrooms and their
View and his opinion was that you know
those restricted measures in schools
were going too far and it was damaging
the education of kids and she tweeted in
December 2020 that it would be a mistake
if the government was to shut down
schools again as they ended up doing one
month later in January
um because by this point schools had
already been closed and then reopened
and there was a suggestion that it could
happen for a second time she was saying
don't do that it'll be damaging to
children's education it should be
avoided and that was one of the things
that was in the report that we've seen
that was flagged by the capitalist
information unit as potential
disinformation
um now the thing that really sticks with
me about that one is earlier on this
year I worked on the lockdown files team
for the telegraph which revealed some of
the decision making that was going on in
government through the use of Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages and we
published dozens of stories about those
messages but some of those stories were
about Gavin Williamson the education
secretary at the time and his reluctance
to close schools in December 2020 at
exactly the same time that this was
being tweeted and Catherine Williams now
says that he wishes that he'd push that
view harder it was his View at the time
the school shouldn't have closed but he
says he wished he'd push that hard he
wished he'd threatened to resign over
the fact that the government wanted to
close schools again that January and so
the interesting thing about those two
things is what Catherine Williamson was
saying a cabinet minister sitting in
cabinet meetings and having
conversations with senior scientists and
Senior officials The View that he was
expressing was the same as the view of a
campaigner on Twitter that was then
being flagged as misinformation and as
far as we understand it potentially even
flagged then to Twitter and
um in a request for it to be taken down
so that gives you a sense of the sort of
the the character keeping schools that
keeping schools open now is is not
deemed disinformation as as generally
that was I think that's probably the
popular opinion now is that we shouldn't
have closed at school but we'll get into
the lockdown fast because you're one of
the journalists on on that story and um
uh interested to hear your more about
that but the the before we do the the
government response to your
investigation has been that
that they didn't ask Tech to censor
anything that wasn't already
breaking the rules of the tech companies
themselves
to to which my immediate response would
be well then why were you doing the work
for the tech companies it wasn't it
isn't it their job to do that themselves
why would a government spend taxpayer
money as you've already said one and a
half million uh uh there's been reports
more still uh why why is it the
responsibility of government to do that
censoring for Tech if it's within their
terms already
well I think the government had a pretty
difficult time during the pandemic
trying to manage the issue of social
media I mean this is the first big scale
um Public Health event for you know 100
years perhaps um certainly of this scale
and governors never faced this problem
before the government in in previous
crises has faced the issue of the press
right and the Press has newspapers have
editors that you can go and speak to
they have journalists that you can
interact with through your press office
their social media is something of a
wild west for for the government and I
think what it shows is a concern
basically that they they weren't able to
um
they weren't able to influence what
people were saying on the internet and
and so their response to that was to say
well if the tech companies aren't going
to do it off their own back what we're
going to do is try and show them what
they should be doing ultimately the
decisions will always still up to Twitch
on Facebook the government doesn't have
the power to shut down content on the
internet you know without the consent of
those tech companies
um but I think it shows anxiety from the
government that there was something
going on here people talking that they
couldn't really influence or control uh
and and so that they felt the need to to
set up these teams to do it there's
there's a link here and you've mentioned
the dcms because this is where the unit
was coming out of but dcms is also at
the Online safety bill is coming out of
here what what's what's the latest on
the Online safety Bill and what what
this similar con I mean do you share
similar concerns about that bill as as
with let's say the counter
disinformation unit well yeah I mean
there's been plenty of concerns about
the Online safety bill because there was
a you know concern that the list of
things that should be taken down by
these tech companies and which actually
the tech companies should face massive
penalties for not removing
um was too long and that you know it
could have potential impacts on free
speech and you know the government had
arguments in the laws about this as well
um I think it is the same Instinct isn't
it it's the same concern that there's
something going on on the internet that
the government would like to regulate
and actually a lot of the stuff that
we're talking about in terms of online
safety is really horrible stuff
stuff that no person really wants to see
going on the internet certainly don't
want children to have access to on the
internet
um but yeah I think it's exactly the
same Instinct and we have to think about
this from the perspective of the tech
companies as well because actually for
Twitter and Facebook all of this stuff
is a huge headache the Online safety
Bill and all of this disinformation
stuff is a huge headache for the tech
companies because basically what the
tech companies wanted is little
regulation as possible they don't want
to have to hire massive regulatory teams
and lawyers to deal with stuff they
certainly don't want the legal
consequences of not following these new
laws and potentially being fine 10 of
their Global profits uh if they break
them so there is a bit of a wrestle
going on here between you know the
government's concerns about
content on the internet uh and these
three these tech companies that would
rather not be considered Publishers
um and would rather say I don't know
something to do with us this you know
people can say what they want on the
internet and there is there is you know
both the Regulatory and a free speech
battle going on there the Free Speech
battle one is is one I've explored a
little bit on this podcast series
um and and there's a sort of line here
you know to what extent do we do we want
free speech my position would be that
even if if it was technically not
correct information that was going out
we needed all Minds on the issue let's
say it's lockdowns or covid we want
maximum voices on it so that we can get
to the truth as soon as you start
uh
censoring people bad ideas can run can
run right do you think do you sense
there's a uh where would you draw on the
line on on the Free Speech issue well
there's a difference here between
misinformation and disinformation
um misinformation is you know someone
getting something wrong putting
something out that's not true by
accident not deliberately and this
information is you deliberately
spreading false narratives about
or whatever the issue is and we've seen
in the past State actors doing that we
know that Russia has got these troll
Farms that spend all day every day
coming up with false narratives to try
and spread dissent in the west and to
try and destabilize governments so I
mean I think I think a lot of people
would say it makes a lot of sense to try
and
deal with that stuff
um to try to try and deal with State
actors isn't that just lies and
propaganda like why are we using the
word disinformation it seems to me that
that's such a new word to put down
people we don't like and we don't agree
with because what's what isn't that just
lying
yeah I mean there's no but I mean I
don't think anyone would have any qualms
about describing what Russia is doing
and you know his lies in propaganda well
when it's used what outside of Russia
when it's used on let's say own British
people or other people in in the west
people who are dissenting voices on
topics like like lockdown we use the
word disinformation it seems to me
that's a way of being pejorative about
uh the people saying the speech so
Russia propaganda aside there there is
there is something there that's a bit
more striking I guess I'm I'm pushing
here because as someone working at the
telegraph in in journalism I'm a little
bit concerned by the the state of
Journalism so
for example I'd have thought that a
story like this where the conservative
government was suppressing speech
a paper like the guardian would be all
over this because it's it's you know it
would be totally with playing to to
their interests if they're well not
playing to their interest rather it's
their responsibility to hold the
conservative government uh um to account
so I I I'm kind of curious by the state
of Journalism and why words like this
information uh come up and why some
stories are not making it and not making
certain papers your story for example
has not had the traction and left
media the Twitter files which was a huge
story about Free Speech barely got
touched by the BBC all the while the BBC
of launching BBC verify uh where they're
um going to tackle this information well
but are journalists supposed to check
whether things are true or false what
what's your take on the stage of
Journalism how do you feel well that's a
big question what's my take on this day
of gender but I think this is a big
thing the journalists are are grappling
with at the moment and defining what
exactly is disinformation and what is
not as you point out is is difficult
um and you know this story that we've
written about these units operating in
government is exactly about that
question is about where do you draw the
line and as far as we can see the
government drew the line pretty
liberally around a lot of people who
were making very sensible arguments
um you're right the BBC has launched
this new BBC verify service and I think
that is aimed at trying to bolster trust
in the BBC by saying you know have a
look behind the curtain let's show you
the processes that we go through in
order to verify information
um
but that is that is what journalists do
right that is the point of the job the
point of the job is you you look at a
piece of information you try and work
out whether or not it's true
um if it's true you write about it if
it's not true you don't you know does
the public necessarily need to be taken
behind the behind the curtain and
showing how that works well I suppose
we'll have to see whether or not BBC
verify does bolster trust in the BBC but
um yeah I think I think all media
companies are grappling with this issue
at the moment particularly when you look
at something like the Ukraine war
whether it's a concerted effort by state
actors to spread lies about what's going
on there um you have to combine that
with traditional journalistic methods
you know people out there with the
notepads and their cameras looking at
what's happening and making up their own
minds uh
so yeah I mean I think it is is one of
the biggest questions that journalists
are facing today is how do you actually
distinguish between truth and falsehood
particularly on the internet where the
rising power of AI and its ability to
falsify things on the internet very
convincingly yeah you know is a bigger
challenge than ever earlier in this
conversation you mentioned that the
rapid response unit which is part of
your report was set up uh after during
the Syrian War am I was that linked to
terrorism specifically or something else
because and the reason I ask is Sarah
Connolly I think was part of a
counter-terrorism unit before and it
strikes me that there's a lineage
with in this country let's say prevent
trying to take down uh terrorist voices
using social media to to organize and
then there's likewise in America I think
you can make a parallel that you you
have the Patriot Act after 9 11 leading
to uh Stellar Wind as as exposed by
Edward Snowden where initially policy
that is designed to protect the the
people of a Nation then goes it seems to
slowly adapt to
you could say suppress or censor do you
think there's a link there what's what's
the is there relevance that Sarah
Connolly was involved in terrorism
before do you think well I mean the
original the original thing was set up
to you know counter false narratives
that were being put around by again by
state actors during the during the
Syrian Civil War and I think a few
people would have an issue with what
that unit was doing there
um but yeah the difficulty with all of
these things is that the government
doesn't really like talking about them
because it provokes exactly these kinds
of debates about what exactly is being
sent to the government hates the
particularly a conservative government
hates the idea that they they should be
censoring anyone online or anywhere else
and so the difficulty with with both
these units and with prevent and and
within and in the states as well is that
these units generally operate
secretively they're kept quiet for
national security reasons and when we
asked uh why that not more information
had not been made available about these
units when we were writing the story the
government told us well for national
security reasons we try and try and keep
this stuff quiet
um well the the question is why are they
doing that why shouldn't the public know
by what metric will you decide whether
or not what I say on Twitter is is
worthy of being taken down or being
flagged to social media companies
um and you know there are people with
their own concerns about the prevent
program and
um the prevent program has faced
accusations of mission creep and of
changing its initial purpose of course
prevent program was set up to prevent
Islamic Terror
um and to
as a sort of early warning system I
suppose to flag the potential
radicalization of people who could go on
to commit terrorist acts in the future
um now its critics argue that it looks
at more far-right terror and also just
general right-wing voices more than it
does anything else there was a story uh
in the mail on Sunday earlier this year
about Jacob Reese morgue the the former
cabinet minister being put on a prevent
list
um you know for a speech that he made in
the public domain and you know there are
people who question whether or not that
unit is really doing what it's there to
do
um but I think the answer to all of
these things is just transparency the
more we know about what these units are
and what they're doing who runs them and
how they make the decisions that they
make the more confidence the government
can expect people to have in the work
that they're doing did your
investigation find there was any link to
intelligence services
uh we didn't find any concrete linked to
intelligent Services no um we know there
was a piece of work done by Big Brother
watch the think tank earlier this year
that looked at some similar themes and
looked at these units as well
um and it found that there was there
wasn't some Army involvement uh in some
of these units during the pandemic we
know that Army units were deployed all
sorts of all over the place for various
different reasons during the pandemic
but the Army does have a dedicated uh
Brigade The 77th Brigade which looks at
misinformation disinformation and
actually you know Works to spread
positive or supportive narratives about
what the British government is doing
Behind Enemy Lines during during
conflict so
um we think that that unit or something
like it was involved as well
um but I mean it's abrogate work then
well you have a misinformation
disinformation Brigade when it goes
Behind Enemy lights yeah I'm not trying
to find a weather enemy I'm not an
expert on this one I'm not an expert on
this one but there is there is a
military Brigade 77th Brigade which is
you know it's not memory guns as
Amendment laptops who were looking at
um you know the information War but the
information war is of course part of the
part of how we do conflict now and
there's always been military
intelligence and there's always been
people doing that stuff but you know now
of course it happens on the internet
rather than uh rather than you know
dropping pamphlets out of airplanes or
whatever we did yeah yeah in 1939.
um you mentioned uh Big Brother watch
there and uh silky Carlo has said that
millions of pounds of taxpayer money has
been spent on these uh disinformation
counter disinformation units and you've
already said that uh they the
government's paid one and a half million
or nearly about one and a half million
to AI the AI logically what is it called
um
is it true that there's how much more do
you than the one and a half million have
they spent of taxpayer money have you
got how much of a concept of how much
they spent on this well we don't have a
total figure of course what we can see
because they're in the public domain is
contracts that the government has taken
out with third-party companies money
that it's paid to them to do it and this
logically these logically contracts are
part of that in fact the government has
been tendering recently for a new
contract to do something quite similar
because we know this unit this unit's
still operating it now sits in DC the
science and technology department
um and so more money is being spent on
on contractors on this all the time of
course the government contracts lots of
things out so third-party companies and
probably doesn't have a dedicated AI
unit that's able to scout social media
in that way
um the thing that we're not able to put
a number on is how much money was spent
inside the department of course if you
have a we don't know how many people are
involved in this team we don't know
exactly how long it was running for we
don't know what sort of resources it had
we don't know what budgets it had so um
my instinct would be that the Lion's
Share of the money that's been spent on
these initiatives has been spent on
public sector workers on
but you know we're certainly talking
well into the millions of pounds yeah uh
so can you can we go back to the
lockdown file so you you mentioned it
earlier and you're one of the
journalists on that when uh Isabel
oakshot shared that 10 000 WhatsApp
messages of Matt Hancock to the
telegraph
what's what's the um what what do you
what do you think stood out from from
from those messages most concerning to
you uh Tony
well I mean there were dozens of stories
that we published as part of that
investigation
um what it showed was a lot of the
advice that was going on behind the
scenes I mean the first story We
published the splash on day one of that
investigation was that the government
was warned uh about the virus spreading
in Care Homes and that became one of the
biggest stories of the pandemic was
about people being discharged from
hospitals who were covered positive when
we didn't have very much testing
capacity and it was difficult to work
out it was positive and who wasn't being
discharged into Care Homes where they
were in contact with other elderly
people we revealed that the government
was warned much earlier than it has ever
been revealed before that that would
happen and they didn't act and well the
the government was in crisis because the
hospitals were all full with elderly
people who had covered
um and it was very difficult to find out
whether or not they did have it because
the testing capacity was so low and so
the government had to make a choice do
you discharge people out of hospitals to
free up hospital beds for other people
who need to be put on ventilators uh or
do you leave them there and what are the
consequences of that and it had always
been the assumption that the government
never really understood the extent to
which the virus was spreading Care Homes
if they weren't to discharge if they
were to discharge
um we revealed that you know Matt
Hancock was warned then that would
happen and ultimately it did and that
was contributed significantly to the
death toll during the pandemic I imagine
that the the lockdown fires are going to
be or the those what's happened should
be important part of the covert inquiry
that starts uh this week what what can
you
um tell me about the covert inquiry and
what do you what do you think we can
expect to come from it well so far the
majority of the stuff that's been
written about the covert inquiry has
been the rail over what material they're
gonna have access to and I think the
important thing to point out is that the
current rate we're not going to be
looking at getting any sort of result
out of the inquiry until 2026 well after
the next election
um which is convenient for the
conservatives of course it was still in
government and we'll be seeking
re-election in a year's time and we'll
be hoping that a lot of you know
material potentially about the
mishandling of the pandemic all the
decisions they made uh won't come out
before then uh but the rationale behind
the lockdown files investigation was to
put out in the public domain messages
that reveal what sort of decision making
was being taken and why uh and there
were those in government in fact it was
the official government line was to say
we're not going to comment on this stuff
we're going to wait for the inquiry in
fact politicians always say that when
something goes wrong they say we're not
going to comment on this we're going to
wait for the outcome of the inquiry I
think what our investigation did was
sped up that process brought out some of
those major issues into the public
domain and put them into the hands of
those who are conducting the inquiry and
said this is the stuff you need to be
looking at and it also set a precedent I
mean the rail that we've been having
over the last few weeks is over the use
of Boris Johnson's messages by the coven
inquiry uh and Boris Johnson said he's
more than happy for his messages to be
handed over the cabinet office doesn't
want them to be handed over because they
worry that it would set a precedent that
other government ministers should also
hand over their phones and there is
concern about what
what those reading being from the
inquiry reading them would would be able
to find by doing that so I think what we
did was
set the tone and we established a
precedent for
those messages being published and
revealed to the public actually how
useful they could be
in looking at the decisions that people
made
I think one of the most important things
about that investigation was to show
just how much ministers were using
WhatsApp to make decisions that's not
something that we've ever really
understood before I mean we all know you
know those of us in Westminster know
that WhatsApp is used on a
minute-by-minute basis to speak to each
other everyone uses WhatsApp that's how
politics is done now but there is an
official system for ministers making
decisions there are civil servants whose
job it is is to sit in meetings and take
minutes and there are policy papers
which as distributed to ministers using
their red boxes and you know there is a
system of accountability and
transparency that we've established for
this exactly this reason what that
investigation showed is the behind the
scenes decisions were being taken and
conversations were being had between
senior people
um that were not ever minuted that were
never meant to be released and the
public was never supposed to see and
what we did was basically pull back the
curtain and say hey well this is what
was going on it's going to be very
revealing because one of the natural
differences is when you're on WhatsApp
you just assuming you're in a private
conversation and if it's actually that's
now
slowly become the formal way of of
government correspond into government
intergovernment correspondence uh that
we can have a completely different see a
dialogue and there's going to be
different manners to it to it all so it
should be pretty interesting yeah I mean
I've noticed myself since we published
that investigation it may be a
coincidence perhaps only taking credit
for for more than I should but
I've noticed that people have started
turning on disappearing messages on
Whatsapp yeah the thing where if you
send a message it deletes within seven
days
um and that means that those messages
disappear from WhatsApp servers they're
not available to anyone anymore and
they're certainly not available to be
published by journalists or visited by
public inquiry in years to come so you
know in a way perhaps it's driven people
underground even further and people are
taking greater measures to to ensure
that their conversations remains it
isn't just significant by the way to uh
politicians and people working in
government it applies to all people if
you want to take someone to court
reliable rather
you have to give up your phone and all
your private emails and private messages
for lawyers to
check even if you believe they were
private they are in the public domain
you so you see this another
person I've interviewed is Jay
bhattacharya who was one of the
signatories of the Great Barrington
declaration and he's been he's exposed
in the states some of the governmental
behavior and on lockdown and covid and
uh he's exposed by suing them he's he's
shown their private messages which is
which is very revealing so it really
applies to anyone now your messages are
not safe legally and relevant to your
investigation as we've been discussing
uh both Jacob Reese MOG and I believe
David Davis has said that part of the
inquiry should be to investigate this
counter disinformation unit do you think
uh an investigation is necessary what is
there even a desire uh do you think to
take this down or is actually do people
generally support a counter
disinformation unit well I think most
people don't know about the capitalist
information Union um you know that was
one of the reasons why it was important
that we wrote that story
um I think there is clearly political
appetite to look into this stuff and
particularly on the conservative
Ventures actually and you have that
slightly strange situation where you've
got a conservative government that you
generally expect to be suspicious of
these kind of initiatives um being
criticized by its own MPS on the back
benches for doing exactly that
um I don't know whether or not it will
become part of the inquiry the prob the
inquiry is already facing a bit of a
problem with Mission creep and with
scope uh and you know there is I mean
already that today there are calls by
trade unions that the pandemic inquiry
should be looking at the last 13 years
of the conservative government and the
impact of austerity on public
institutions which ultimately led to
um you know difficulties in dealing with
the pandemic so everyone in a way is
kind of tacking on their own personal
projects into the covered inquiry and
hoping that that will be investigated
too in the inquiry if it's going to have
any chance of reporting you know in the
next 10 years needs to try and narrow
its scope as much as possible but I
think you know this is something that
people have major concerns about and at
the very least what those MPS will be
hoping for is for the government to make
a more a fuller public Declaration of
what exactly they were up to during the
pandemic to stop saying this is a matter
of National Security and therefore we
can't talk about it and actually say
look this is how many people we had
there this is what they were doing this
is where they worked this is how much
stuff they flagged here's how we decided
what we flagged and what we didn't and
to people who
had their content
unfairly flagged as disinformation
perhaps to apologize and to say you know
we made a mistake and if we were going
to do the same thing again we would keep
the net a bit more tightly focused on
what we were actually trying to achieve
which is tackle genuinely harmful
narratives about covert
is there anything else we can expect
from your investigations on counter
disinformation unit and is the are the
investigations ongoing is is there more
to be revealed well there are still
things that we don't know about these
units
um and one of the interesting
elements of it is how exactly how they
interacted with social media companies
and I said to you earlier that we don't
fully understand exactly who was making
those decisions and how stuff was being
flagged
um we do know because we've seen an
email that was passed to Big Brother
watch that think tank from Twitter that
about six in ten of the requests that
were made for content to be removed were
actually ignored to a set actually it
doesn't really violate our terms of
service at all so we don't want to do
anything about it and we also know from
his public comments about our story that
Elon Musk doesn't think that Twitter's
interaction with the government was
great he wasn't he said it was terrible
so perhaps we can expect you know sort
of forward-looking newsy where we could
expect to see
Twitter do something about it perhaps or
Twitter to make a statement about what
it might do in the future
um and that perhaps would give people
who have free speech concerns about
these units a bit more confidence about
about what could happen next time around
so I've been quite concerned about how
few journalists are exploring and
investigating censorship across the
world uh obviously I mentioned the
Twitter files journalists and and
Michael schellenberger who's one of
those journalists republished your your
investigation on his American newsletter
public and he's been very vocal about it
but it's as I've mentioned earlier in
this interview I've been concerned by
how little
other mainstream media have not picked
up on it and so I wish you and your
investigation team uh well firstly
congratulations on breaking this in
important story and and um I wish you
all the best in continuing to pursue
what I deem exceptionally important um
issues and
um uh I look forward to following your
writing so Tony diver thank you so much
for speaking with me today thank you for
having me
[Music]
thank you